[Applause]
I was in the wilderness but you found me
and um like all the best directors
you merely just showed me where to go to
get to where I needed to be Brendan
Frazier fights back tears as he accepts
a Critics Choice Award for best actor on
Sunday he nabbed the trophy for his
highly acclaimed performance in the well
do you forget
the feeling
wow
people are incapable
of not caring
people are amazing and the role is being
widely recognized as brynden's Hollywood
comeback if you like a guy like Charlie
who I played in this movie in any way
you struggle with
obesity worry you just feel like you're
in a dark sea I want you to know
that if you too can have this strength
to just get to your feet and go to the
light good things will happen
yeah Brendan didn't hold back any
emotions on stage and backstage things
weren't any different
I never anticipated what this moment
would feel like because I had no idea
I'm still pretty new to this so you'll
forgive me if I'm trying to get used to
it
um
maybe I never will and that's okay
um
but I know I'm grateful
fans are totally here for this
Renaissance it was never that far away
I guess as we'll say you can't get rid
of me that easy
throughout the world's press run
Brendan's been getting Tons of love
and while he's not used to all the
attention he's sure enough confident in
where he's headed practice that face of
What's it gonna look like if I do hear
my name if I don't hear my name
I'm new to this whole routine so I'm
gonna have to practice that one before
we find ourselves lucky enough to be in
that seat at that time I still feel like
I'm just getting started to tell you the
truth
I'm not done yet
we're young and ambitious still it's
good it's going to be an interesting
Journey it's It's Not Over
[Music]